>> Hello, everyone.
Good afternoon.
Welcome to the AI
Infrastructure and
the two-hour session.
This session we will
have two talks.
One is about backend optimizer
for deep learning computation.
Another one is for AI print form.
So, I'm Jilong Xue from
Microsoft Research, Asia.
So, I will start first talk.
It's glad to introduce
our recent project
called the Wolong: A Backend
Optimizer for
Deep Learning Computation.
In recent years,
deep learning has gained
many success in the areas such
as vision and speech
and NLP and so on.
Along with this success,
there are many
emerging innovations.
In one side is
a deep learning side
are continuously inventing
new models and workload patterns.
For example, beyond the RNN
and CNN, the typical models,
there are also new workload
patterns like GAN,
reinforcement learning and
graph neural networks.
So, in other sides of
the hardware vendors
are actually inventing
new accelerators for
speed up the computation.
For example, beyond
the CPU, GPU and FPGA,
there are some more and
more new basic accelerators
and high-speed network links.
So, using this situations,
there were deep learning
frameworks were proposed.
For example, like
Tensorflow, NTK, Caffe2,
for user to easily
write a DN program,
and the computer on
different hardware devices.
Typically, these
frameworks epsilon and
deep learning computation
as a dataflow graph,
the node, it's work is to permit
operators and the edge
represents the tensor data.
So, using dataflow graph
as a programming IR,
you do get efficient,
expensive and
programming flexibility.
However, it also brings
the challenge of how to
effectively do graph computation
over different devices.
So, we think a systematic way
is to leverage our compiler and
optimize our infrastructure to
bridge the IR framework
and the hardware.
This is because compilers can
combine both the information from
application pattern and
the hardware feature
to make a best match.
As it has a global view
of the dataflow graph,
so the compiler and optimizer can
also optimize for
distributed computation.
Thus, such infrastructure is
critical for both the training
and inference scenario.
Based on this observation,
we started our research
project one year ago.
So, we proposed a system
called the Wolong,
which is optimizer stack for
deep learning computation.
The motivation of
Wolong is to adjust
deep learning performance
organization problem
in a systematic way.
Specifically, we're
going to leverage
the general graph organization,
passes and the leveraging
the principle for software
and hardware co-design and
just-in-time compiler.
The right figure is
the architecture of Wolong.
Wolong has three
optimizer module;
the global optimizer,
local optimizer
and tensor placement
and optimizer.
So, the global optimizer has
a global view of the computation
graph and conducts
a distributed organization
through graph
partitioning and leverage
of the hardware features.
The local optimizer mainly
optimize the subgraph after
the graph partitioning for
a specific device level
using the JIT compiler,
and the tensor placement
optimizer mainly optimize
for tensor layout
and replacement.
All these optimizations, Wolong
designing automatic
and transparent way.
So, Wolong generate target user,
optimizes the communication and
the execution and
the memory efficiencies.
So, first let's look at
a case of global optimizer.
The subtitle is a fast
distributed deep
learning computation over RDMA.
As I introduced it before,
a deep learning computation
is modeled as a dataflow graph.
To execute the data flow graph
in distributed servers.
So, DL framework first
need to partition
the graph and the dispatch
each sub-graph to
corresponding servers.
After partitioning, F0 user
end go across two servers.
We need to insert a pair of
standard and the receiving nodes.
So, these parallel of
node are responsible for
a real data transmission
during the computation.
Worth to mention,
this kind of mechanism is
generally to express
both modal parallelism,
the data-parallel pattern,
which are a common way to scale
deep learning computation
in distributed servers.
In such a general framework,
the communication has to leverage
a general communication library.
However, in most deep
learning scenarios,
the tensor transmission in
such a framework brings
significant overhead,
which becomes the major
bottleneck for scalability.
To demonstrate this, we use
a simple micro benchmark,
we just send a tensor
with different side from
one server to another server.
This figure measures the latency
of different tensor size.
As we can see, you
measure the same network,
there is up to 10x
latency gap between
the general RPC library
and Nobel optimizer of
the program which
carefully leverage RDMA.
So, to understand
the overhead of RPC,
let's go to a little
bit more details.
We observed that
the major overhead of
RPC is caused by memory copy,
and it is inherently
unavoidable for
such a general library.
This is because the general
IPS is designed for
dynamic data structure and
it's a lack of knowledge about
the actual data placement
and the message size.
As illustrated in
the right figure,
a message is sent
from sender has to be
first copied from
application memory
to the RPC managed memory,
and then serialize
into a larger buffer
to better leverage
the batch efficiency.
When it comes to
memory, disorientation
and memory copy also happened
in the receiver side.
To adjust this overhand,
we cannot leverage
such a general library.
Instead, we should use
a right time optimizer,
which can dynamically decide
the memory placement according to
the specific computation
workload and
the net network topology to
completely remove
the memory overhead.
Just in our distributed
graph optimization,
we combine both the properties
are computed in
a graph and RDMA network feature.
First, for the tensor structure,
unlike the general messy type,
the tensor data in
deep learning computation
has several special properties.
First, it consists of
a plain byte array with
sufficiently large size often
from several kilobytes
to megabytes.
Due to this, we actually do
not require
data serialization and
deserialization in
this transformation.
Due to excess pattern of
tensors already sequential,
we also do not require
extra batching,
but all this information
can only be decided
in the right time.
So, second, with RDMA
hardware and the protocol,
we can manage both the local
and distributed memory
in a unified view.
We can do efficient
the memory copy
between host memory through
the one side RDMA and read
and write primitives,
and efficient memory copy
between device memory
to host memory with
GPU direct RDMA.
This global graph optimizer for
distributed computation
is a systematic way
to address scalability
of the other work,
this is because the first
global optimizer account
has entire view of and
the control of the
memory placement
among the devices servers.
Second, it is capable of making
global optimizer strategy
for this tensor data placement
in the right time.
So, based on these observations,
we designed a new
communication mechanism in
our optimizer for distributed
computation over RDMA.
In this mechanism,
it has two phases;
the graph analyzing phase and
the graph execution phase.
First, before
the graph is executed,
there is a graph analyzing phase.
In the sender side,
our optimizer first detect
physical memory address
of the sending tensor,
and it tells the information
to the tensor manager
to reallocate it as
the RDMA compatible memory.
So, this can dynamically
avoid the memory copy
in the sender side.
Similarly, in the receiver side,
as your graph is analyzing,
we can know the receiving tensor
side beforehand.
So, we can pre-allocate
the receiving tensor as
RDMA compatible memory,
to avoid the receiver side
in the memory copy overhead.
So, after the graph
analyzing phase,
in the execution phase,
when the sender know
there is ready to send
and source tensor,
it can just issue
a one-sided RDMA right command.
RDMA unique will
directly copy the source
tensor to test
the tensor's memory.
In the receiver side,
since the RDMA didn't
have the notification mechanism,
so the receiver operator
will continuously pulling
off a megabyte until
the value turned to one,
which will mean
the whole tensor data
has already arrived.
So, it just simply
passes a reference of tensor
to the downside operators.
As we can see,
this communication mechanism
of neural optimizer,
we can completely remove
the memory copy overhead in
the both sender side
and the receiver side,
and most importantly without
affecting the usability.
So, this is the
performance evaluation
for our optimizer,
the communication mechanism on
both deep learning frameworks and
a real training workload.
So, our experiments are
conducting a cluster with
eight silvers to evaluate
the performance we
implement our optimizer
in TensorFlow.
The left figure shows
the training throughput
of TensorFlow and
our optimizer version,
our set of deep learning
benchmarks including RN,
CN, and the fully-connected work.
As we can see with
our transparent organization,
in same hardware environment,
the performance can
be improved from
1.8 times to 8.1 times.
We also demonstrated the benefits
our end-to-end sequence to
sequence translation model using
public data sets which is
showing in the right figure.
The y-axis is
the perplexity which
measures the convergence quality.
The lower, the better.
The x-axis is the training time.
As we can see with optimization,
the current density can be
sped up by two to three times.
So, after demonstrating
the benefit of
our global optimizer for
distributed deep
learning computation,
now let's look at our case
of local optimizer.
So, we are mainly talking about
the kernel fusion for
deep learning on GPU.
The local optimizer
is merely optimizing
subgraph unless specific device.
Currently we mainly
target through GPU.
So, as I introduced before,
deep learning framework
often model computation
as a graph of operators.
Using graph has
several advantages.
First it, has a good
expressivity to represent
arbitrary neural network
structure through just
composing the graph with
the primitive operators.
Second, it is flexible
to run the graph on
multiple devices or
multiple servers
through just a different graph
partitioning strategies.
However, this flexibility comes
with a significant overhead.
Since the typical
DL model contains
[inaudible] even more operators,
scheduling overhead is
a major bottleneck
for the computation.
So, to schedule this overhead,
we are introducing the
overhead like kernel launch
overhand and the cross operator
communication overhand.
Also, since the primitive
operator is the two fine-grade,
it is hard to leverage vendors
library for a specific
computation workload.
To demonstrate this, we
compared the execution time of
a 80-step LSTM model in
TensorFlow and CUDNN.
CUDNN is a vendor provided
library from Nvidia.
In TensorFlow, this model is
constructed by about 1,600
operators and the framework
has to schedule out of
these operators in this subgraph
during the computation.
However, in CUDNN,
since it is highly
optimized for removing
scheduling overhead,
it can order magnitude
performance improvements
for the same workload.
We also tried to manually fuse
all the kernels into
one CUDNN kernel.
It shows that we can get
similar performance with CUDNN.
So, now let's have
a high-level comparison of
deep learning frameworks and
the hardware specific
library in terms of
programming flexibility and
the computation efficiency.
You see this is
the general challenge of
encountered DL frameworks.
First, the deep
learning frameworks
like TensorFlow, PyTorch,
and the CNTK, has
designed for user
to easily program
their deep DL models.
This is has mostly embrace
the flexibility and
expressivity through using
the graph operators
to model computation.
But they target less about
the extreme performance
of organizations.
The other side, the DL
libraries are designed by
hardware vendors to push
the extreme performance boundary.
However, they are
mostly hand-tuned and
highly optimized for
submissive sub-module,
it is impossible to handle
customized or new
network structure,
which means they have
good efficiency but
poor flexibility to
spot arbitrary model.
That's if we have a compiler
that can dynamically
generates a library like
a code in the right time
based on input data flow graph
for deep learning frameworks,
we can get both
the flexibility of
the overwork and
the computation efficiency.
So, under this situation,
we propose the compiler
stack for optimizing
deep learning computation
so-called Wolong.
Wolong compiler takes input as
a computation graph and it has
two optimization layers
the graph level optimizer
and the target specific
data compiler.
The graph level organizer applies
a set of target independent
graph optimization passes
through recovery rewriting.
So, commonly sets as CSEE,
constant folding, and so on.
So, spatial organization in
the user layer is
operator batching,
which can automatically
batch same type of
operators to better leverage
the best efficiency,
which I will introduce later.
The second layer is the target
specific JIT compiler which
can fuse all the compiler
subgraph into efficient kernel,
commonly mainly
targeted to GPU device.
The organization in
this optimizer include
static shape inference
and type inference,
and static memory planning,
and aggressive kernel fusion.
So, here is the general
execution flow of
Wolong compiler.
The graph level
organizer works before
the graph execution and
the JIT compiler works
during the execution.
First, in the graph
level organizer,
when getting an input graph,
it first detect some subgraph
that can apply optimizations.
For example, if the graph
contains same type of operators,
the operator batching patch
will automatically merge
these operators into
a larger one through
graph rewritting.
So, after the graph optimization,
we start the real execution.
For a subgraph that is
the first time to be executed,
our compiler will conduct
a shape inference and a type
inference for this subgraph,
as well as a static
memory planning process
based on the graph
and the GPU features.
After that, we automatically
generate a fuse
the kernel code for
the whole subgraph and
use the JIT compiler to
compile the code
into a new kernel.
Finally we replace
the original operators
in the subgraph in
this new compiled kernel
and then execute it.
So, in later iterations,
if the graph and the input
shapes has never been changed,
it will hit the cache
and directly
execute it from
pre-compiled kernel.
Since we dynamically fused
all the operators of the
subgraph into a single kernel,
it can remove all the
scheduling overhead.
In the following slides I
will introduce a case of
operator batching and the
details of a JIT compiler.
So, first, let's look at how
the operator batching in
graph level organizer works.
Here we introduce the case of
Mat multiplication merging.
As we know,
Mat multiplications is
a very common operator
in DL workloads.
It has the mathematical
equivalent to lose.
If two Mat operator shares
one same input tensor,
we can concatenate
the other inputs to
merge these two MatMul
as a larger one.
As the outputs of
the merged MatMul
is equivalent to
the concatenation of
the outputs of the two
original MatMul operators.
Based on this issue,
we can actually
automatically detects
this pattern in our optimizer
and rewrite the graphs
through Insert Concat and
discrete operator
to automatically
merge the MatMul operators.
So, after graph rewriting,
we can do further optimizations.
So, our tensor placement
optimizer will get
this information and it will
track this input tensor
and allocate them physically
continuously across
the memory so that
the Concat operator can
overwrite the memory copy during
its computation as illustrated
in the right figure.
With such kind of
a graph level rewriting
optimization and
memory placement optimization,
we can transparently optimize
the graph for better performance.
So, after the graph optimization,
let's move to
the JIT Compiler part.
So, in this talk we'll
really focused on how to
do the kernel fusion
in our JIT compiler.
Compared with other
optimization frameworks,
our goal is to conduct
a very aggressive kernel fusion.
Ideally, we would like to fuse
the whole subgraph
into a single kernel
to completely remove the
scheduling overhead.
First, let's start from
element-wise kind of fusion.
This type of operators includes
the binary operators
like the and,
sub, multiply, divide, and so on,
and the unitary operators
like sigmoid, and so on.
For example if we want to
compute a sigmoid of x1+x2,
the computation graph constructed
by your framework will contain
two element operators
and a sigmoid operator,
and so in the left figure.
So, the right figure this is
a corresponding element-wise
data dependency graph.
As we can see for
element-wise operators,
there is no
cross-elements dependency
for this computation.
So, we can simply assign
the computation for
each element to
a single [inaudible] and leverage
the [inaudible] register memory
to shares their
intermediate results.
So, for this workload,
the generated code look
nicely in the figure.
It's relatively trivial.
Since the fusion and device
kernel is really simple.
So, many other
compiler [inaudible]
also support this kind of fusion.
However, fusions doesn't
element-wise operator.
We think it's not enough
because the element-wise
operator only occupies
a very small fraction of
the other operator sets.
That's our goal is to do
aggressive kernel fusion to
fuse arbitrary operators.
To support arbitrary
kernel fusion,
there are some challenge
we need to address.
First, unlike
the element-wise operator
two non element-wise operator
often has cross data
elements dependencies.
We have to carefully control
the dependency for
each convenience thread.
Second, grade level global
synchronization inquiry is
a critical permitive forces
kind of workload fusion.
However, current
GPU architecture has
fundamental challenge to support
a general global synchronization.
Certain some
communication between
operator has to rely
on the device memory,
which may increase
the memory usage.
We have to carefully optimize
the memory usage and
the buffer allocation.
To get better understand
let's look at an example for
fusion to continuous
MatMul operator.
Since each thread off
the second MatMul has
to read almost out
the data element from other
thread of the first MatMul.
So, a realistic way to do
the fusion is to store
the results first
MatMul into device memory
and the second MatMul
can directly read the inputs
from intermediate buffer.
So, the right figure
is pseudocode
for this kind of fusion.
We can see, we insert
a global barrier
between the two
MatMul function call.
So however, the fact
is in GPU architecture
this code is really
challenging to run.
So, to understand
why the challenge
is happening for
GPU architecture.
So, to first we need to
understand the- let's look
at how the current DL
frameworks schedule
dataflow graph in GPU.
So, typically the
DL framework uses
CPU to schedule operators
and the GPU is responsible
for executing
each operators kernel.
So, the GPU often consists of
several stream processors,
which can concurrently execute
block task of GPU kernel.
Let's say there is a graph
with only two operators,
MatMul and the convolution.
The convolution either read
the result of the MatMul.
To run this graph in GPU,
DL framework has to schedule
this two operators one by one.
For each operator, we need
to explicitly split it as
multiple block tasks
according to the data size,
and schedule them on to
multiple GPU stream processors.
Due to the limited number
of stream processors,
the blocks has to be
implicitly execute
in several batches like this.
So then, the second operator is
scheduled in a similar way.
As I mentioned before,
if the graph contains
a lot of operators,
the kernel launching and
the operator scheduler will
become significant overhead.
So, a straightforward way
to remove this overhead is
fusing all the operators of
several graphs into
a single GPU kernel.
For example, if you want to fuse
the MatMul and
the convolution within
a single kernel so we can
compose them as two-stage.
The first stage do the MatMul and
the second stage do
the convolution.
So consequently,
the other block paths
also include a two-stage.
However, since this two kernel
has cross-validated data
dependencies we have to insert
a barrier between
the two-stages in the kernel.
So, for the outer
blocks it also has
the- so each block has to
enter a global barrier.
However, as I
mentioned it before,
due to a limited SM resources,
only the first several blocks of
the kernel were
real as scheduled.
They will be blocked in
waiting for barrier.
So, as the GPU has
no block contacts switch
the later several blocks
will never be scheduled.
So, this kernel will
fail to execute.
So, to address these issues
we proposed to use
the persistent threads and
the virtual block mechanism.
To fuse the same two operators
into a single kernel,
refers to the limited number of
physical blocks off
the fused kernel according to
the available resources so that
all the blocks can be
executed concurrently.
Then, we treat the original
blocks of each operator as
a virtual block and assign them
to physical blocks in
a round-robin way.
We implemented this
through remapping
their block ID in the
code generation time.
Then we are free to insert
a barrier between the two-stage
of virtual blocks since
all the physical block
already active.
With this mechanism we can fuse
all the kernel into a single GPU
as long as we can generate
each operators self code.
So, till now to fuse
multiple operators we are
actually generating
a statistic sequence
of code for each operator.
For example, for
the left dataflow graph
with three operators,
they will be
sequentially assigned to
physical blocks like this.
However, since the sigmoid,
let's say the graph,
since the sigmoid operator
and the end operator are
small operators and they
have no data dependencies,
if we use a counter
DL framework they
can leverage
data parallelization.
So, in our fusion
frameworks there
is some underutilization
for GPU resources.
To further push resource usage
we support the kernel
packing mechanism,
which you can pack
the small kernels into
a more compact way during
the virtual block assignment.
So, we can pack
the end operator into
the sigmoid operators batch.
In this way we can exploit
the graph level paralyze
and removes kernel launch
overhead in the same time.
Okay. So, this is a way of how to
generate to fuse
the kernel coding over compiler.
Basically, first for each
operator we need to register
its kernel source
code and some other
meta information to
our code generator.
We can only fuse the operator
that has been registered.
For arbitrary graph to be fused,
we first conduct
shipping inference
and the memory place planning
paths and then generate
the function cause
for each operators.
For example, for
this graph we can
first generate
the sigmoid and then
the MatMul and the
final is for the real
operators in this way.
So, during the process we
will automatically insert
a barrier we need it and
the packing kernel if possible.
Currently, with
all these spots a lot of
operators we are still in
the more into the framework.
So, now let's look at our
memory performance scale
of a kernel fusion.
For the RNN inference
benchmark with
80-steps LSTM as we show
you at the beginning.
Currently, our compiler can
automatically fuse
and then compile
the whole graph with
1,600 operators into
a single GPU kernel.
The right figure demonstrates
the performance comparison
with original TensorFlow.
The bar with the title
OpBatch means we only
apply the operator batching
optimizations in the graph
layer level optimizations.
The fusion bar is the final
result of the kernel fusion.
We can see with our
compiler we can get
about 10x speedup
for this workload.
So, in conclusion we think
compiler infrastructure
is critical for both
cloud and the edge AI
because they can
automatically and
transparently optimize both
the distributed training and
the local inference
on different devices.
I also think our system
innovation is the key to bridge
the application and
diverse hardware.
Since the current DFL already
abstract a common IR,
which means the dataflow graph
IR and we can leverage this
to co-design software and
hardware for extreme efficiency.
We also have developed
a Wolong prototype to
demonstrate the
initial improvements.
It's up to eight times
speed up for training
and 10x speedup on the
inference workload. Thank you.
That's my talk.
So, do you have any questions?
>> They're the two protects?
>> Yeah. It's two parts, but it
can integrate into same platform.
Because Wolong is mostly target
to the framework, so
computation framework,
and the pi is telling
you on how to schedule
job to the different servers.
So, after pi schedule into
a specific servers or
GPUs so Wolong can
apply its organization.
So, it can be integrated into
a same platform but
two different system.
>> So, why two?
>> You can treat them as
two modules in the same system.
>> Two module?
>> Yeah. But actually it's
two different system.
>> Okay.
>> Thank you.
>> [inaudible].
>> Hold on.
>> Thank you.
>> So, the global miser
part is mostly for
multiple servers
and the local miser
is for just the single server.
>> Thank you.
>> So, when you are applying
this technology to
the parameter server,
just for example.
So, do you do any
compression on the traffic
between the nodes
and also the RPS?
>> So, yeah.
Currently, we are not
applying the compression
stuff in this work,
but the compression is,
I think the technique
of compression is
orthogonal to this technique.
So, we can also
apply the compressor
into the transformation.
It can further reduce
the communication overhead.
Yeah. Thank you. Okay, if
there's no other question
let's welcome to
the next speaker.
>> Good afternoon.
My name is Fan Yang from
Systems Research Group MS,
Microsoft Research Asia.
Today, I'm going to
introduce OpenPAI:
The Open Source Initiative
for AI Platform in China.
So, here is the background.
So, we all know that AI
becomes one of the major focus
and the very heated topic
across academia and
the industries.
We believe that there is
these major opportunities
to democratize AI through
the innovations on
AI infrastructure
that can lower the bar for
new commerce to
facilitate AI education
and to speed up the AI research.
Also, that could potentially
help accelerate the penetration
of AI technologies across
industries especially for
the traditional industries.
So, we feel that
the current status of
the AI platform is
still in early stage.
We find that there exist
a ad hoc ways to build and
deploy an AI platform.
It's relatively easy to build
a small-scale platforms with
narrowed, specific purpose.
But we actually need to
help the entire industry.
We actually need
a platform that works in
different environment and
application scenarios.
That includes the
on-premise, cloud,
and even hybrid
hosting environment.
Also, that the AI
platform not only can
support a domain service
speaker application
like an image or video,
speech, language,
but also they need
to support them all
in one platform,
and also for the AI applications
in a certain vertical domain.
This AI platform need to
be highly compatible,
need to be extensible,
it has a very good
manageability and efficiency.
So before I dig into the details,
I need to emphasize again
the importance of
the AI platform.
The AI platform actually
provide the
infrastructure support
for the advance of
the AI technologies.
It actually support
the Deep Learning
algorithms and frameworks,
and the AI platform also
should manage hardware
in a easy way.
A good platform can boost
the innovation and
the productivity
of different kinds of
AI research field.
It allows the researchers and
the AI practitioners to focus
on the innovation itself,
instead of the hassles of
infrastructure construction,
deployment, management,
and optimization.
A good AI platform could
enable result sharing.
A good platform can help
build a community for
mutual knowledge sharing
and to help each
other to leverage
the previous research result,
and thus can speed
up the innovation.
So, an open platform for
AI R&D and education,
we feel that it actually helped
the co-development
of AI innovation,
education, and
the platform evolution.
So a good platform,
we can leverage
this platform to design
the AI course project to
perform training to grow
the AI talent pool.
Also, an open source,
the platform can add
open source that
the platform can help to
encourage the results sharing
and for collaborative innovation.
So here is the overview of
the AI platform that in my mind.
The underlying infrastructure
layer including hardware
and the various of
the Deep Learning technology
we have already built.
Upon that, we need
a management layer to manage
the heterogeneous cluster for
resource management
and scheduling.
We also, as Gino mentioned,
that we also need
a platform to host as
a system-level intelligent
and optimization.
Also, we could have the platform
to support Deep Learning
and the intelligence exploration.
Based upon the platform,
you can build,
share the results for
practice or for education,
and also the platform can
petition a host that the label,
the Deep Learning data.
Also, you can leverage
the platform and also
leverage the tools
for management integration and
the AI lifecycle management,
or also compiler optimization.
The cognitive capability
built on the platform,
including natural language,
understanding visual perception,
speech and recognition, as I
mentioned, across
different domain.
So let me focus on
the middle layer,
the platform to manage
the heterogeneous cluster.
So we open sourced a
PAI called the OpenPAI,
a platform for AI.
So this platform is
GPU cluster management
infrastructure.
It has the following features:
First, it's open.
So it's open source,
it's licensed under MIT license,
and it's actually operated in
the open collaboration model.
We actually work with
various partners,
I will mention the details later,
and to develop and evolve
the platform together.
The OpenPAI is
actually extensible.
It not only support
all the major Deep
Learning frameworks,
it also, I mean,
extensible to support
a new workload.
It also supported,
diversify their hardware
including FPGA,
GPU, and the ASIC,
given that the drivers
are available.
OpenPAI has a modular design.
So, you actually embraced
the microservice design paradigm.
So, every service
run in a container.
So this microservice choice
can help us replace
a certain component,
PAI component are very easily,
for example, if you would like to
try a different storage option,
you can switch from,
for example, HDFS to cluster FS.
PAI also have a good efficiency.
It supports fine-grained
the GPO scheduling,
it also support
high-speed network
including RDMA extension.
PAI also has a relatively
good manageability.
It actually provide a web UI for
platform operator to manage
and monitor the platform.
It also help the Deep
Learning user to manage job,
a submission job, or
even monitor the
hardware utilization.
PAI provides some
fault-tolerance capability.
So you don't have to
worry about the failure.
Also, PAI learns a lot
from Microsoft's
internal practice.
So, we actually reproduce
the production environment and
the realistic
industrial usage case
for a Deep Learning
model training scenario.
Here is a high level overview
of the OpenPAI architecture.
The underlying is
the host environment
that including Cloud.
Private Cloud, or
on-premise cluster.
That's running on top of
heterogeneous hardware,
GPU, CPU, FPGA, RDMA, etc.
On top of that, we support,
we leverage Docker and Kubernetes
to perform container
orchestration,
and we provide tools to deploy
the platform easily and
also to upgrade
and maintain this.
Also, we have job management,
resource management, etc.
So, one of the key things
in market as read, is that,
we try to provide a
standardized interface
to the deep learning workload,
and to the platform
management tools.
So, that as long as
the interface are centralized,
all the deep learning workloads
or traditional big data workload
can leverage this
centralized API to run
on this open pipe platform.
This would ensure
the portability of the workload.
Meaning that once you
successfully run
deep learning job in
one PAI cluster instance,
it can apply to running on
other PAI deployment as well.
Also, this interface and
the runtime support enabled
the innovation of high level
AI service like AutoML, etc.
Here is a little bit more details
of the our current
implementation.
For example, as I
mentioned I use Docker,
we use Kubernetes for
cluster management.
On top of that, for storage,
our current storage option
is HDFS because that is one
of the most popular
distributed storage solution.
We use Hadoop with
our own extension of GPU support
for complicated GPU scheduling
as well as multi-tenancy support.
We now support our
deep learning workload
and some of the big data like
Spark and we are also
developing our own Auto ML,
our reasons and
the platforms that I
will mention that
briefly later on.
So, with this platform,
we believe we can build
a open ecosystem.
So, our initial engagement with
China AI Community is
to have a community tool
with the AI platform,
we can have a lot of shared
resource and tools and the
build the cognitive ability,
so that we can help
in research in
AI education as well
as gross talent pool.
The Microsoft Research
Asia now work with
four major Chinese universities
to have China Open AI
platform and aliens.
Those four universities
including Peking Universities,
Chinese University of Science
and Technology of China,
and Xi'an Jiaotong University,
and Zhejiang University.
I would like to provide
a one case study for the schools
of Information Science
and Technology of USTC.
This is the previous practice,
they have 300 AI
researchers and students,
with approximately 400 GPU.
Their current pain point
is major about
operation overhead because
that those are AI scientists,
they are not the infrastructure
system researchers
or IT professionals.
So, they feel that to operate
on a relatively
large-scale GPU cluster,
it's a lot of work,
and for each students
and researchers to run
assertions of
deep learning workload
on the cluster require
a lot of work.
You need to make
sure your version
is correct, for example,
you have to have the right
version of TensorFlow, etc.
You have to be
careful not to screw
up other people's environment
like the corrected version of
Cu-DNNeven GPU driver
or something like that.
As a result, that
the previous cluster utilization
is relatively low.
So, we use OpenPAI deployment.
We have, as I mentioned before,
we have a web UI
interface to help to
monitor and manage
that GPU cluster,
and we actually lower
the learning curve for
the AI researchers to run
deep learning workload.
The research results can share
the cross team with Docker image
and the job configuration files
that require different kind
of resource like,
for example, number
of GPUs for the job.
The new user like a new student
when they try to learn,
to try to run some workflow
that they can just
jump start with
some pre-build Docker images.
There are GPU cluster
utilization improved
with our scheduler mechanisms.
They leveraged the platform
and the ground their workload,
and we are happy to see that
the OpenPAI platform can
help them win some of
the top and prestigious
award in CVPR.
So, to summarize a platform,
OpenPAI essentially,
a platform for AI innovation.
It provided much needed
a playground for AI research
and development.
PAI actually represent a class
of realistic and
the production environment,
where AI researchers
should target that,
because that, as I
mentioned before,
Microsoft internal
production environments
very much like OpenPAI.
It's a hassle-free platform
for non-professionals.
By non-professional, I mean,
IT professionals or
system researcher.
We have a relatively low
operational overhead,
and we provide a WebUI-based job
in management tools,
so that AI researchers can
easily use the platform
to run their AI workload.
So, the researchers can focus on
AI research itself instead
of a tedious IT stuff.
With the platform,
we can help the
results sharing and reproduce
the research result.
As you might know that,
it's very hard for
AI researchers to reproduce
other people's workload because
that they often require
a lot of parameter tuning.
So, our platform can help
you with Docker image
that include
all the parameter you
set for the paper
you've published.
Also, the platform can help
the system research itself.
Here, I'd like to
give a few example of
the research opportunities
systems group are working on.
For example, we
try to explore it,
to understand what is
the right system primitive for
deep learning scheduling in
large-scale GPU scheduling.
For example, in
the big data area,
big data jobs are expressively
MapReduce task and later
on they usually have
a data scheduling that.
Before the big data area,
if you look at
the distributed process,
they usually,
the scheduling primitives,
usually timesharing
migration, et cetera.
So, what is the right
primitive before
deep learning's workload is
one of our research focus.
Also, we feel that
because deep learning workload
usually require large data
and larger neural
model size so as
to have a relatively
good accuracy.
So, we feel that how to
manage GPU memory more
efficiently is one of
the potential opportunities
we can exploit.
For example, we can leverage
a very traditional system concept
like virtual memory and
some of the technology like
memory compression
essentially to optimize
the GPU management during
deep learning model chaining.
We have identified
several case where
certain deep learning
technology like the Auto ML,
have reasons may have
some very subtle interplay with
the underlying systems
cluster scheduling.
How to optimize
those deep learning job
that can target for
achieving the good models,
having a good neural
model instead of
only speed up one
specific deep learning
chaining possession.
It's one of the interesting
research topic,
and also like cross job
optimization and how to
identify fairness in the case of
deep learning workload
especially for the GPU.
Those are very interesting
research opportunities
that the system research
itself can help.
So, to conclude,
we have a platform
that can facilitate
the research on
artificial intelligence.
It provide an efficient
and ease of use AI
infrastructure that can help
to put the AI research
into practice,
and the platform itself is
open collaboration model.
We actually developed
the platform
with the university together,
and we have an open community.
We start from China
and we certainly
welcome university and the
researchers or even industry,
the practitioners across
the worldwide to join
us to develop
a platform together.
Okay, thank you.
So, after that I would like
to spend a few slides to
introduce another piece of work
our team is working on which is
called a Neural
Network Intelligence.
So here, I would like to
show just a few slides.
>> Listen to this.
>> Here is the overall process
of the deep learning
developers daily practice.
So, first, they usually can
mine or search some code for
certain deep learning
neural model practice from
GitHub or related website,
and our Neural Network
Intelligence platform
can index those popular code
and neural models,
and recommend
this neural network model
architecture to the user.
The Neural Network Intelligence
also provide a lightweight open
source to package
for user to run
their own training sessions
to find a good neural model.
Finally, we have visualized
the tools to edit, search,
and debug the neural
network model intense
during the Auto ML
training session.
We know that the the
traditional Auto ML algorithm
has been developed from
a simple Hyper-parameter Tuning,
to more advanced neural
architecture search
including, for example,
evolutionary-based search
reinforce learning-based search
or other more advanced
technology.
Then later on, we have seen
that people are starting to
apply neuro-evolutional
transfer learning
in this kind of
Neural Architecture Search.
So, our NNI package
actually support
all these kinds of technology.
Also, we provide
a markup language
for Search Spaces Specification.
For example, those markup
showed in orange,
it's a way for users to specify
their their choice
during the search space.
So we feel that using
a markup language
actually provide
deep learning researcher a
very handy tools to
specify certain Neural
Architectures Search.
Okay. So, we are
going to open source
this package in
maybe one or two months
depending on the legal process
while going through.
We hope that in the future,
people will use this NNI package
to apply a certain
Auto ML research
so we can enable
more rapid innovation in
the Auto ML research itself.
Okay. So, that is
all for our talk.
Thank you.
Any questions? Yes.
>> So, I am interested
in the Auto ML part,
so could you tell me more
about like what kind
of Auto ML functionality
to support,
and what's the usage
over consumption from
the customer,and is it quickly
growing feature and so on?
>> So, we decide to
open source the NNI as
a lightweight package.
So, if you only have
one GPU server, you can use it.
If you have for example 10
GPU servers, you can use it.
If you happen to have
hundreds or thousands of
GPU cluster that managed
by open [inaudible] ,
you can also use it.
So, it's quite flexible.
The package itself does include
a certain a typical or
classic Auto ML algorithm.
For example, a random search,
grid search, or based method.
But we also provide
standardized interface allowing
deep learning researchers
to develop their own
Auto ML algorithm,
which is actually one of
the active research
topic right now.
So, this is one of
the target customers
we try to support, AI innovator.
The other part of
the customer is that,
some of the people
actually do not have
too much knowledge on
deep learning itself,
and they would like to,
for example, try some CNN model.
But in order to
better leverage the CNN model,
they have to do some fine tune.
For example, one of the very
typical changing practices is
to return only the
last few layers
of the CNN model so as to have
a better classification result.
Then, we have these tools
that can help you automatically.
You don't have to do anything.
You just leveraging some of
the pre-configured package.
So, this is just like
a Microsoft custom vision
of Google's Auto ML,
except that you can
run the entire package
open-source and own
your own cluster so
you can play with.
You don't have to be
forced to locking into
any cloud offerings.
I hope that answers
some of your questions.
>> Thank you.
>> [inaudible] support the FPGA?
>> We do not support
the FPGA yet.
Our design actually,
taking FPGA into
account but we need to
verify that with the driver.
So, I assume that if the driver
doesn't have any problem,
then we don't have
any problem because
that we treat GPU as
just one specified co-processor,
and the FPGA is no
different than that.
Okay. Thank you.